[موسيقى]
تصنيف ومجلات فورد الامريكيه لملياردورات
العالم كشف ان سنه 2022 كانت قاسيه على
اغنى اثرياء العالم تريليونان دولار كانت
خسارتهم العام الماضي لتصبح ثروتهم 12.7
تريليون دولار بعد ان كانت 13.1 تريليون
دولار عام
202168 مليار درهم في سنه 2022 بعد ان خرج
من دائره الملياردرات نحو 329 شخصا الصين
اكثر الدول التي تاثر اثريائها العام
الماضي اذا خرج نحو 87 مليارديرا صينيا من
قائمه فورس لاثرياء العالم متاثرين
بالعقوبات الامريكيه على قطاع التكنولوجيا
روسيا الخاسر الثاني بعد ان خرج 34
مليارديرا روسيا من قائمه الاثرياء بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا ولا قال الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تتصدر العالم في عدد
الملياردورات ب 735 مليارديرا في حين
احتفظت الصين بالمرتبه الثانيه ب 607
مليارت